happy tuesday so as war rages on what
are the other world leaders doing in
response
in britain the guy with fish and chips
on his head
actually met with oil and gas industries
yesterday to figure out his country's
energy plan as it looks to move away
from russian gas
now compare that to us
where the remedial class known as the
biden administration looks to teenage
tick-tockers to coordinate messaging on
russia's invasion of ukraine and blame
putin for rising gas prices
not surprising in a white house where
the only adult thing
are the diapers
why is gas so expensive and why is the
united states inflation rate at a
four-time decade high i had the
opportunity to ask the white house why
gas down the street is seven dollars and
here's what they said russia is one of
the top three producers of oil and it is
actually their number one revenue source
now with putin starting this horrific
fight between ukraine and russia nobody
wants to work with him and do an
international trade so with people being
scared of war and limited resources
prices are bound to go up as well
that was terrible
so that was one of the 30 influencers at
a march zoom meeting with white house
officials and nsc staffers and they
definitely influenced me
to throw up all over my lap
what's joe going to do next
hit up the half naked soccer moms on
only fans for immigration tips
so while ukrainians die and americans
raid their 401ks to buy groceries our
leaders are chatting up obnoxious brats
about how to lie to the american people
but maybe that's the white house's
emotional level
and rather than trying to figure out a
way to stop the next world war they fret
about rising gas prices ruining their
political chances
because with libs it only comes down to
holding power
but this is also what happens when there
are no adults in the room
back in the day serious people took
serious things seriously
last time i checked during the cuban
missile crisis jfk wasn't getting his
military advice from the mickey mouse
club
what the hell did annette funicello know
about war anyway
now we go to tiktok which is used to
gaslight the american people but they're
not even good at gaslighting unless
you're talking about joe with a big
lighter after a bowl of beans
meanwhile be careful if you dare
question joining the war
then you become a traitor here are the
co-hosts of the view otherwise known as
the five stooges
suggesting the doj investigate tucker
carlson and tulsi gabbard
doj in the same way that it is setting
up a task force to investigate oligarchs
should look into people who are russian
propagandists and shilling for putin
they used to arrest people for doing
stuff like this if they thought you were
uh colluding with a russian agent if
they thought you were putting out
information or taking information and
handing over to russia now you know
there seems to be no bars and people are
not being told to hate putin
putin doesn't need a reason to be hated
it's pretty much clear
like a
it's like a break room in an inner
circle of hell they used to arrest
people for stuff like this
what stuff do you mean like how bad your
show is because that offense could be
next
what an interesting view to hold if you
have your head up your ass but this
modern mccarthyism is spreading like a
swalwell fart
here's claire mccaskill
tucker carlson and others are really
really close to treason in terms of what
they're saying and parroting
what
is is putin's dream
close to treason how cowardly mitt
romney tweeted that gabbard is guilty of
spewing treasonous lies
maybe mick can find tulsi in his binders
full of women if he looks under courage
we know mitt's an our binder filed under
schmuck
so questioning military intervention is
treasonous
even if you're a combat veteran like
tulsi disagree with her or not you gotta
admit she has more balls than a bucket
of titleists
so what happened to free thought what
happened to avoiding world war three i
guess it's easy to push war when you're
here far away from the mess that's why i
don't do it it's a lot like all those tv
hosts telling you to stay home
indefinitely during coven because they
still got paid they could do their show
from home
this is no different but since i'm not
going anywhere i'm sure as hell not
going to tell you to go somewhere and
die meanwhile the president mulls
whether he should fly to europe after
sending the town cackler in
he's probably worrying about those
tricky stairs that he has to navigate to
get up on air force one
it appears now he may be going to europe
next week next week
great
what's the hurry it's only women and
children being slaughtered why not go
tomorrow or today what's the delay you
too busy choosing a flavor of ice cream
for the ride over
let's see what joe's mulling
hey
come on look look
don't give me that mccarthyism stuff
that was not
it was a different time back then
back then you had senators and
congressmen calling people reds we don't
do that
no i get celebrities and social media
people to do it for me
yeah but i'm go i'm going over there i'm
going to brussels
uh i i i don't really like their sprouts
they don't agree with me
no i don't like the way they smell
either i'd rather smell a nice
shampooed head
get ready
ready
it's weird people are called traitors
for mulling about not entering a war yet
others can casually mull over sending
your kids to a foreign war and yet
they're patriotic
but if you want this war then what's the
next step you okay with more dead
including americans these are questions
the left used to ask google anything
about vietnam protesters i mean did we
really run out of afghanistan so we
could run headfirst into war in europe i
mean at least give us a little
in-between war pallet cleanser like a
dish of sorbet or an invasion of cuba
the number one goal should be to end
this thing as fast as possible which
calls for some audacious diplomacy not
mulling it over not sending kamala not
indulging tiktok which is owned by china
but we live in a time where it seems war
is preferable to mediation and if you
don't go with the flow you might be
called a traitor i call it mccarthyism
but i don't want to offend the irish so
close to the 17th
[Applause]
series
he's like your favorite salad plenty of
green and perfectly dressed host of
making money on fox business network
charles payne
next year when cat turns 50. he'll still
look 12. host of the guy benson show and
fox news contributor guy benson
next year when guy turns 12 she will
still look 50. fox news contributor cat
jim
finally bodyguard wrestler actor there's
nothing he can't do except fit into a
prius my massive sidekick in the nwa's
world television champion
tyrus
uh
guy thank you for getting the day off
from the library
coming down here um and when i it uh i
gather your grandmother's in the
audience bobby who cancers overdue by
the way what you're on our list your
copy is overdue by the way overrated
book tropic of cancer henry miller
there's only one good scene it's no
naked lunch
guy what
sending go joe going to europe that
gonna help what's going to help right
now what would you do if it was
president benson which will never happen
you know why anyway is it because i was
born in saudi arabia yes that's it
because it's that is true
but i could be president i'm not running
don't worry america uh i don't know what
could help right now and i think
humility is probably a good thing for
people in our position right this is not
an area of expertise on my part it seems
to me as a total amateur who's of course
very concerned about what's happening
very much on the side of ukraine and not
russia i feel like there has to be
some potential opportunity for putin to
extricate himself from the mess that he
has caused and the destruction that he's
wreaking right now and what worries me
is do we offer such concessions we
meaning sort of the freedom loving west
such concessions that it rewards what
he's done
that is one side of this but you also
need to give him potentially something
where he can basically lie to his people
and say i've achieved this and now
finally the killing can stop i just
don't know what that balance looks like
but
maybe that's the off-ramp here yeah and
the thing is people will say one you you
know you cannot give him an off-ramp
because then that's a reward you can't
give him too many off-ramps too early
but there's a thing about russians it's
a it's a they are a status seeking
face-saving culture they need something
to save face so he can go back
maybe it's these territories who knows
but you can't give away the story right
you don't want to be like hey you've
achieved this so we're giving you a lot
look it's it's brutal and you're not
going to sit here on your show and
pretend like i've got easy answers
because easy answers do not exist well i
have the easy answers and i can pretend
you however can't but i'm glad you
noticed that charles it's great to see
you it's been a while to be here yeah
you look fantastic thank you as always
great suits
thank you very much
my first day here i wore a suit yeah and
i got in the elevator and there was pain
and by the time we got off the elevator
i threw my suit in the trash
yeah but i don't have the i mean that's
every day that's not just for this yeah
he's church dressed 24 7. you have a
total commitment to who you are every
day whereas i every day i wake up i
never know what's going to happen but
you know i'm charles payne i'm going to
wear a suit screw everybody charles i
have a question for you i forgot what it
was i want to know what's in your head
about this are you with guy and you see
kind of it seems like there's no way out
of this other than just it keeps going
for a while yeah it's weird when people
say we can't give putin a victory uh
because he's going to have some kind of
a victory uh it looks like because of
the options that might have mitigated
that first of all listen we're all
playing to a degree and i i commend you
for trying not to right now just like we
all became sort of scientists during
covey we all become armed chair generals
right because when this type i listen
it's just so frustrating to hear the
administration talk
uh about things now that you know it's
inflation you saw it coming since last
may you wonder well if we saw this
coming why didn't they get the mig 29
right why didn't they get the armament
when you watched 190 000 troops line up
the border and so you know
it's just and that's the infuriating
part is like maybe this could have been
prevented and certainly it could have
been mitigated and now we're now now
it's behind and and listen vladimir
putin is going to have a period victory
the bottom line
and and and so ultimately george
washington was a great general because
he knew how to retreat
sometimes you have to reset
and and i think unfortunately
in spite of all the bravery we've seen
from the ukrainian people and zilinski
they've got to find a way to reset and
live again so they could fight another
day that's such a good point you know uh
pyrrhic victory is a win that comes
amidst a greater future loss just wanted
to make sure you understood that being a
young because i'm a woman no because
you're so young and speaking of young
okay you i'm looking at these tick
tockers who are you know half your age
yes because i'm old yes
does it bother you that they're get they
have a bigger hold on power than you do
that this tick-tocker is explaining gas
policy to america and you aren't
no i have no interest in explaining gas
policy to anyone though uh i think i
would probably do a better job than an
18 year old which is true for most
things not all yes um i i guess that
it's just frustrating that it seems that
their focus even now is how do we not
get blamed for the problem
and not solving the
tons and tons of actual problems that
they should be working on instead i
think that this administration has been
very image and politics focused over
actual solutions
and that's a real big loss for all of us
nothing exists until there's a poll on
it right once they get the polling then
crime's a problem but if there's no poll
there's no crime all right tyrus in your
red fox shirt
he's phenomenal yes wrap it up for us
he'd be calling he'd be calling edith
right now
it wasn't either it was was it edith
yeah she kicked ass and took names
esther was the one yes yes i am too
young for this reference
he had the best junk yard yeah he really
did and speaking of junkyard a great way
to segue into this
i cannot be more
concerned about our
current future
when the white house sat down in a
meeting with the supposedly the best and
brightest minds of the democratic party
and decided the best way to talk to
america was through tick tock yeah
that goes back to my i always talk about
that polite racism
that the progressives indulgent this is
a polite you're too stupid to understand
so we have to they think the average
american
is as smart as they need somebody on
tick tock to read something right that
didn't even make sense yes the
guy's face when it was four times decade
we all charles payne is a great number
man he's an ex a librarian you know what
i'm saying and they couldn't figure it
out yeah when you look at that for what
it is i am terrified of what is going to
happen in the next few months based on
this type of decision making yeah it's
crazy hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else